hello everyone I'm Jesse and welcome to
my kitchen today I'm going to share some
ways with you that you can save money by
re growing your own veggies at home
using food scraps so the first one that
I want to share with you is lettuce a
really easy way to regrow what you want
to do with your lettuce is when you buy
your iceberg lettuce you can cut about
an inch the two inches off the bottom
part that will be where the roots will
grow and basically you just want to put
it in a container small container of
water to where it does not fill all the
way about halfway is pretty good you
just basically change out your water
every day and you will start to see this
grow you don't even need to put any soil
or in it for the first few days
basically I've had this one for about
six days now and I've just been changing
out the water and you can already see
it's got about three to four inches of
growth so at this point now now that it
has established growth I can actually
take it outside and plant it or if you
choose to have it inside you can just
basically wait until it grows a little
bit longer and eat it from there now the
thing about that is it will not
reproduce as in if you cut it that part
it's not going to continuously be an
endless supply so you will want to plant
it if you want it to keep growing the
next one that I want to share with you
is basically the same thing except
obviously a different plant and it is
celery I've done the same thing with the
celery I did it about at the same time
small container again fill it about half
way with water and you can start to see
little buds growing I don't know if
they're called buds or what they're
called but basically it's starting to
have new growth here the celery has
grown a little bit slower but I can do
the same thing as with the lettuce once
it starts to establish growth or you see
roots growing you can take it outside
and plant it from there or keep it
inside make sure you just keep changing
the water on a daily basis the next one
that I want to share with you is garlic
it is so easy to grow and I've done it
here at my house I didn't have a garden
or an extra planter so I just use my
aloe and planted it right next to
and we'll have to replant it later
because they're watering schedule is
different but it's so easy you basically
take a garlic clove especially the ones
that you start to see growth in like
such as this one you can take the root
and towards the bottom part of your
planter plant it halfway so that part of
it exposed in your planter so what I did
with that one is I have actually only
watered it once I wanted it when I
planted it to make sure that it was salt
and moist and this has grown in just
about like three days now I believe it
has grown quite quickly so at this point
now I can take it outside and replant it
now garlic though does take a few months
to grow so you're gonna have to be
patient with that one this next one I
have not done yet because we just moved
into this house so I didn't have a
garden yet but I wanted to still show
you because we have done it in the past
and it works great is you take a sweet
potato or a potato whichever one you
have around your house and these little
spots here these little nodes
they're called eyes so what you want to
do with these is you can cut it into
pieces I mean you can plant the whole
potato if you want to but you don't have
to do that you can plant in different
sections you have to make sure that you
cut at least one eye per each area that
you're planting I prefer to do two or
three now what you do with that is you
have to cut it into pieces and this part
the little eye section has to go upwards
because that is what's going to be the
growth it's gonna create the plant for
you I went ahead and cut this one just
so that you could see but I cannot use
this one you have to use ones that
already have the little sprouts growing
on them you know you've had those the
ones that you've forgot you have
potatoes forgot to cook them and then
started growing so those are perfect
you basically have to cut a few now if I
were to plant it in the ground I would
have to make sure to cut it a few inches
deep and these little nodes facing
upwards I am by no means an expert in
planting this is something new that I'm
trying out now that we've moved into our
own home so be patient if it doesn't
work out in the beginning sometimes we
he'll plants because we just love them
too much and we overwater them or we
forget and we underwater them and that
is okay the thing is you tried there are
already scraps so if you waste them you
were gonna throw them away anyway so try
it out it might surprise you and you
might have new veggies to share with
others
[Music]